let's start with the smimplest polynomial, a monomial. A monomial consists of
only one term, and it could contain the product of numbers and variables. When
we see a number next to a variable, we assume that there's a multiplication
between the two. But, like many things in math, we don't often show it. Here are
lot of examples of monomials. I've rearranged our monomials into certain groups.
Here's a group of four monomials, and in this group, I have a constant
coefficient and a variable. The variable is x in three of these, but it doesn't
always have to be. In this one, it's y. These monomials are simply just
constants. They don't even contain variables. This monomial is negative and it
contains variables with exponents. Monomials can be positive or negative, like
in the first group. And finally, this last group shows an example where we have
a constant coefficient and multiple variables multiplied together. Each of these
is an example of a monomial.